gagner en créativité retrouver
l'équilibré ou instant cocooning pour
chaque humeur son parfum c'est en tout
cas ce que geneviève souhaite faire
découvrir des soins à base d'huiles
essentielles
on utilise donc l'aromathérapie et
l'olfactothérapie puisque
ce que l'on va faire si on va pulvériser
donc dans les mains on va frotter pour
pour faire évaporer l'alcool et ensuite
on va respirer l'odeur donc qui va
amener des nutriments
au niveau 2 du corps des produits
présentés lors du marché de noël de
l'association créactive les visiteurs
avaient le choix entre différents stands
épicerie fine photographie et
accessoires textiles
sabine a rejoint l'association il ya six
mois c'est sa première vente sur
l'opportunité de se faire connaître
et puis aussi de tisser des liens de se
former de le réseau très important dans
nos métiers donc ce n'est pas à négliger
c'est vrai quand on travaille en
indépendance on est souvent seul et que
ce moteur personnel on a quelquefois du
mal à le prouver donc là on se soutient
les unes les autres
entreprendre au féminin la devise de
l'association saint-quentinoise elle
compte plus de 130 membres
une dizaine d'entre elles ont joué les
mères noël lors de ce marché